time magazine acknowledges that elites
manipulated the levers of power during
election 2020 and
the new york times fires a reporter for
not being racist i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
thousands of my listeners have already
secured their internet join them
at expressvpn.com we'll get to all the
news in just one moment and there is a
lot
of news but why don't we begin with the
fact that we are now at the mercy of one
party control and agenda driven by tax
and spend economics and only getting the
social ramifications fiscally you can
expect compounded growth of the national
debt the systematic devaluation of the
united states dollar a lot of people
worry about inflation these days well
what is a way that you and your
investment portfolio can protect against
the predations of inflation
well you can go diversify into some
precious metals and you can talk to my
friends over
at birch gold group i know the people at
perch gold group i trust the people at
birch gold group i've been working with
them for years
birch gold group will help you diversify
a portion of your savings in ira or
eligible 401k into an ira backed by gold
and silver their premier precious metals
ira company in the united states with an
a
plus better business bureau rating
countless five star views thousands of
satisfied customers there's a tidal wave
of inflation it will come
at some point at the very least you
should be hedging your bets and gold can
be that hedge text ben
to 47 47 47 for your free information
kit on precious metals ira
or to speak with a birch gold
representative today time is running out
you can protect your savings right now
text ben 247 47 47 to get started again
text my name ben to 47 47 47 to talk
with my friends over
at birch gold group okay so few quick
notes
to begin about last night's super bowl
so
it is the only nfl game i have watched
this season because of all the wokeness
and i will say it was kind of
astonishing how missing in action the
wokeness was
at the super bowl which makes sense
because the nfl is not stupid enough
to try and cram that down the throats of
100 million americans during their
biggest broadcast of the year and the
biggest event
in american entertainment and so it was
the usual stuff it was patriotism and
unity and togetherness
and all of the rest that's not to say
that it didn't have its bizarre moments
like the halftime show but
it was it was not a good game but tom
brady demonstrates once again that he is
the greatest quarterback of all time at
ten super bowls he's seven and three in
those super bowls and you just have to
you just have to admire the quality i
mean you really do and you have to
admire the quality by the way of
defenses
of tampa bay's defensive scheme and they
really stymied patrick mahomes but
that's enough
sports talk we'll get to the cultural
side of this i will say that the
halftime show was super weird
um i i know that it's not aimed at me i
know that when people think of like
chief demographic
for the weekend they don't think of me
because i listen to classical music
and read straight the lyrics of cardi b
but with that said i thought
that even for a weird halftime show this
one was super
duper weird uh i think my favorite part
there were a couple parts that were
pretty great one was when he was
the weeknd which i assume was his given
name like he was born his mother looked
at him and called him
the weeknd but in any case i assume that
um you know he was he was stumbling
through the the mirrored halls
with a camera up in his face that was
like me after a second coved shot
right there and then i don't know if
this was meant to be like joe biden's
covent coveted troops masked coming for
you if you don't wear
a mask or what this was supposed to be
but the uh the creepy
red-coated fascist marchers with no
faces coming at you in the night was
ambition
that's i also he should pay some
royalties to michael jackson this is
just the thriller video isn't it
so we had him doing a little bit of uh
of michael jackson
dancing and then we have uh like the
thriller video here now we have the the
coveted fascist troops coming for you so
that's
that's exciting stuff it was weird it
was weird
and also um isn't this bruno mars song
not different song
okay so that's that
yeah that's not brutal mars that's
that's the weekend okay so in any case
um that was one sort of weird highlight
of the show but when it came to the
commercials the commercial that everyone
is talking about this morning
the commercial that's got everybody hot
and bothered is this commercial
narrated by bruce springsteen for jeep
okay so there's always one of these
commercials during the super bowl where
some major companies like wouldn't it be
great if america got together
a few years back during the recession
clint eastwood did one
from one of the car companies i'm trying
to remember which car company which
shows you how successful the ad was
in retrospect but jeep had this ad with
bruce springsteen narrating and when i
think
of people who represent middle america i
think of the guy from new jersey
with the earring who votes democrat all
the time
quintessential americans i think of of
like people who represent
the middle of america the partisan
middle of america i tend to think of
bruce
springsteen's this is and he puts on a
cowboy hat which
like that makes him the the second most
awkward person to have put on a cowboy
hat i would be number one on that list
after a company moved to tennessee in
any case here was the here was the ad
for a jeep and a lot of people in the
media were just in love with this brian
stelter was like i wish this could have
gone on
for an hour in an hour oh
no you you don't because the ad is super
boring and it says nothing and it just
demonstrates sort of where we are
politically
is that this sort of pap is now popular
with the left specifically
because the ad says nothing it says that
we are all supposed to be reunited the
idea here is that donald trump is gone
of course
and therefore we can all reunite around
shared values
like churches that the left wants to
invade and revoke its nonprofit status
and also dirt apparently
here's the ad there's a chapel in kansas
standing on the exact
center of the lower 48. the middle has
been a hard place to get to lately
between red and blue between
servant and citizen between our freedom
and our fear we need the middle
we just have to remember the very soil
we stand on
is common ground
to the reunited states of america and it
sounds like
super nice and bland and uh and
meaningless
like literally completely meaningless
there's nothing there
uh my i do like when he he likes dirt
that that is one of my favorite parts
i don't know if that's the dirt that
better work it after he lost his ted
cruz or
like the very soil we stand on is common
ground
okay well yes the entire earth in fact
is made out of
generally the same materials and so we
therefore have common ground with like
all the people like us and in yemen
common ground
because we're on a planet together so
that's that's exciting stuff
also a lot of shots of churches there
and uh the equality act
not very much in favor of uh the
churches so
this but this is the new unity right the
new unity is get on board
we're unified we're moving forward
together and oh by the way
if you disagree with us you're not part
of the unity you're not part of the unit
that's the subtext there because
when you think of unifying political
figures bruce springsteen is a partisan
democrat has performed to like every dnc
since 1873
th that guy is is not a unifying figure
in any way shape or form
and so i i calls for unity that actually
have content like why don't we recommit
to our local communities and helping one
like that would be nice but that's not
what that's about right
it's the reunited states of america
because trump tours part
and now now we can be reunited
nobody mentioned that trump won kansas
like don't tell him don't tell him okay
in any case
all of this is part of a of a broader
manipulation that is currently happening
in the united states
in which we are all supposed to have
bought into the new golden age the
post-partisan age of unity
ushered in by joe biden's administration
and it's going to be great guys it's
going to be great and in fact we should
celebrate
the the accession of joe biden to the
presidency and we should celebrate
everybody who helped make that happen
including people who
soared and manipulated the system now
note that i am not going to connect here
i'm not going to contend
that voter fraud voter regularity
decided the election i don't think they
did i did not make that contention
since literally day one i said that i
did not think it was true i did not
think there was evidence to back in the
evidence was not brought
however i did say since day one that
there are systems of power in this
in this country institutions of power
controlled by the left at the top level
and those were in fact manipulated in
order to
rig the body politic in favor of
particular points of view and this can
happen when you have an entire
mainstream establishment media on one
side of the political aisle this can
happen when for example
you black out an entire late breaking
story on the president's son
and his relationship with foreign powers
and what the president knew about that
and when
as it did happen with all of social
media to the new york post story this
can happen
when you have the social media giants
cracking down on people with dissenting
points of view
and downgrading traffic to particular
websites that do not reflect that point
of view
if you have the institutions of power in
the united states all controlled by one
side of the political island those
institution of powers kick into gear
that is going to have an effect on the
election obviously you don't have to
expressly suggest that people had their
votes switched or their votes stolen
in order to point out that when you have
institutions of power that have a heavy
impact on how people live and how people
think and how people
consume information and that that
certainly can have an impact on how an
election goes
and this is not a theory a molly ball
over a time magazine
has a piece that the left is celebrating
but really should scare the living hell
out of everybody
molly ball who is on the left short a
piece for time it's called the secret
history of the shadow campaign that
saved the 2020 election
this is one of my favorite things that
is happening in the media right now and
when i say favorite i mean least
favorite
you have members of the media who are
openly acknowledging that blue america
has taken control of the levers of power
in every major institution
and are wielding those levers of power
against you
right in order to manipulate you in
order to change your life and then if
you say
hey wait a second all of these
institutions seem like they're
controlled by the left
and they're being wielded against me
then the same media will say you're
paranoid
you're paranoid it's not happening to
you we have
jim vanderhey from axios literally
writing that
blue america is in control of every
major institution in the united states
from hollywood
to sports to corporate america to social
media
to government and that they are using
that power in order to
rethink how freedom of speech is done
and then when people like me
say that on the show then axios reports
hey look at these right-wingers this is
their new narrative it's not my
narrative dude it's your narrative you
literally wrote that narrative
because you happen to be telling the
truth about this we're gonna get to what
time magazine said
actually happened during election 2020
because again
the the institutional obstacles to open
debate
in the united states are massive and
they are becoming ingrained and it's
extraordinarily dangerous
you're being manipulated you're being
manipulated and the left is sometimes
openly admitting they are manipulating
you
we'll get to this in just one second
first let's talk about some of that
manipulation so one of the things that
you may have noticed is that big tech
companies
are now changing all of their standards
they have these sort of arbitrary and
capricious standards they apply
when they feel like it against people
they don't like or outlets they don't
like
but how exactly are they monetizing the
way they're monetizing is they're using
your data so why exactly would you give
your data to companies who are then
going to use that data to make money and
then turn your own views
against you instead protect your
personal data from bigtech with the vpn
i trust for my online protection
expressvpn when i use expressvpn my
connection gets rerouted through their
secure encrypted servers so these
companies can't see my ip address at all
my internet activity becomes anonymized
my network data is encrypted
i recommend expressvpn to anyone who
uses the internet so you know
everyone the best part you don't need to
be tech savvy at all to use expressvpn
just download the app on your phone or
computer tap one button now you are
protected protect your internet activity
with the vpn i use
every single day visit expressvpn.com to
get three extra months free
on that one-year package that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
spending get three extra months for free
expressvpn.com
to protect your data today okay so molly
ball has a peace and time magazine and
here is what she says
she says a weird thing happened right
after the november third election
nothing
the nation was braced for chaos liberal
groups had vowed to take to the streets
planning hundreds of protests across the
country
right-wing militias were girding for
battle in a poll before election day 75
percent of americans voiced concern
about violence
then an eerie quiet descended as
president trump refused to concede the
response was not mass action but
crickets when media organizations called
the race for joe biden on november 7th
jubilation broke out instead as people
thronged cities across the united states
to celebrate the democratic process
that resulted in trump's ouster a second
odd thing happened amid trump's attempts
to reverse the result
corporate america turned on him hundreds
of major business leaders
many of whom head back to trump's
candidacy and supported his policies
called on him to concede
to the president something felt a miss
it was all very very strange trump said
on december 2nd
within days after the election we
witnessed an orchestrated effort to
anoint the winner even while many key
states were still being counted
in a way says molly ball in time
magazine trump was right
there was a conspiracy unfolding behind
the scenes one that both curtailed the
protests and coordinated the resistance
from ceos
both surprises were the result of an
informal alliance between left-wing
activists and business titans the pact
was formalized in a ter's
little noticed joint statement of the us
chamber of commerce and afl-cio
published on election day
both sides would come to see it as some
sort of implicit bargain inspired by the
summer's massive sometimes destructive
racial justice protests
in which the forces of labor came
together with the forces of capital to
keep the
peace and opposite trump's assault on
democracy
so she's talking about the post-election
period there but then she says ah yeah
there's the pre-election period too
right and here's
what she says molly ball the handshake
between business and labor
was just one component of a vast
cross-partisan campaign to protect the
election
an extraordinary shadow effort dedicated
not to winning the vote but to ensuring
it would be free and fair credible and
uncorrupted
for more than a year a loosely organized
coalition of operatives scrambled to
shore up america's institutions
as they came under simultaneous attack
from a remorseless panic and an
autocratically inclined president so the
way that molly ball is pitching this is
that all of these left-wing institutions
they
threw themselves into high gear in order
to ensure
free and fair and wonderful and clean
elections and wow what an amazing job
they did and the result of that amazing
job is joe biden as president now
to somebody who's not on the left what
that actually looks like is hey look at
all these institutions of power that
kicked into high gear in order to
sometimes suppress opinion
in order to downgrade particular
informational dissemination
in order to change the rules of voting
so they had universal mail-in voting
five months early
in many of these states before much of
the information for the election was
actually
relevant or available but remember molly
balls of the left so this is a
celebratory article right
she says so much of the activity took
place on the left it was separate from
the biden campaign and crossed
ideological lines with crucial
contributions
by non-partisan and conservative actors
the scenario the shadow campaigners were
desperate to stop was not a trump
victory it was an election so calamitous
no result could be discerned at all well
actually it was kind of more
like the trump victory these people
generally speaking
were pretty concerned with the outcome
of the vote not merely the mechanisms
of the vote that is a lot of revisionist
history right there says molly ball
their work touched
every aspect of the election they got
states to change voting systems and laws
and help secure hundreds of millions
in public and private funding they
fended off voter suppression lawsuits
okay voter suppression lawsuits are also
things like voter id and
lawsuits that challenge whether votes
should be cast in a particular way
things like vote gathering right ballot
harvesting
they recruited armies of poll workers
and got millions of people to vote by
mail for the first time that's just
called voter turnout
right that's a political campaign they
successfully pressured here's the part
that's great they successfully pressured
social media companies to take a harder
line against disinformation
and used data-driven strategies to fight
viral smears oh you mean
they rigged the levers of informational
dissemination in the united states so
that they would be the sole
arbiters of what information should
actually be spread during the election
sounds on the up and up they executed
national public awareness campaigns that
helped americans understand how the vote
count would unfold over days and weeks
after election day they monitored every
pressure point to ensure trump could not
overturn
the election so
here what exactly does that mean so
molly ball says
the participants want the secret history
of the 2020 elections hold
even though it sounds like a paranoid
fever dream a well-funded cabal of
powerful people ranging across
industries and ideologies
working together behind the scenes to
influence perceptions change rules and
laws
steer media coverage and control the
flow of information
they were not rigging the election they
were fortifying it oh
that's what was it so by the way if
trump had won and they'd done all the
exact same things do you think molly
ball would be writing about the
fortified election
or do you think she'd be writing about
how corrupt the election was
yeah so what kinds of stuff did they do
in order to quote unquote fortify
the election fortify the election we'll
get to that in just one second first
let us talk about a great valentine's
day gift so jewelry is my duke my go-to
valentine's day gift for my wife and the
place that i go
for the best jewelry at the best
possible price my friends over at the
pearl source at the pearl source you get
the highest quality pearl jewelry at up
to 70
off retail prices why well because the
pearl source cuts out the middle man
they eliminate traditional five times
markups by jewelry stores they sell
directly to you
the consumer if you can't find that
perfect item at your local jewelry store
you can shop safely and securely from
the comfort of your home
at the pearl source you'll find the
largest selections of pearls anywhere
available
and each jewelry piece is custom-made
just for you if you need it quickly for
valentine's day no problem
the pearl source offers fast and free
two-day shipping on every order with
zero contact delivery everything comes
beautifully packaged in an elegant
jewelry box so it's ready to be given as
a gift
and if you're not sure she'll love your
gift no worries the pearl source comes
with that no hassle 60-day money-back
guarantee so you
really have nothing to lose i know the
people who run the pearl source and the
people who own it
they're extraordinarily honest wonderful
people you can help out their business
and by the way get your
loved one a fantastic fantastic gift at
a price
that you can't get anywhere else don't
overpay for your jewelry go to the pearl
source save up to 70
off retail prices for a limited time
listeners in my show get 20
off your entire order for valentine's
day go to thepearlsource.com enter promo
code bennett checkout for 20
off your entire order go straight to the
source the pearl source again that's
pearls the pearlsource.com
slash ben enter promo code ben at
checkout for the special deal okay so
molly ball
writing in time magazine and she talks
about how all of these groups basically
got together in order to quote unquote
fortify the election so what exactly did
that fortification look like
well it looked like an alliance between
the afl cio
and the chamber of congress chamber of
commerce
and the head one of the heads of these
unions
was a guy named mike pot horzer okay he
was the senior advisor to the president
of the afl cio he put together a memo
and he started making connections with
people
on march 3rd pod horzer drafted a
three-page confidential memo titled
threats to the 2020 election
trump has made it clear this will not be
a fair election that he will reject
anything
but his own reelection as fake and
rigged he wrote on november 3rd should
the media report otherwise he will use
the right wing information system to
establish his narrative and incite his
supporters to protest
the memo laid out four categories of
challenges a tax on voters a tax on
election administration attacks on his
political opponents and efforts to
reverse the results
of the election so what did they do they
kicked into high gear
for rapid mail and voting and
by the way they started and this is the
part that's scarier to me they started
securing
the methods of informational
distribution so according to mollyball
at time
bad actors spreading false information
is nothing new for decades campaigns
have grappled with everything from
anonymous calls claiming the election
has been rescheduled to flyers spreading
nasty smears about candidates families
but trump's lies and conspiracy theories
the viral force of social media and the
involvement of foreign meddlers
made disinformation a broader deeper
threat to the 2020 vote okay so there's
something you have to understand about
the whole disinformation misinformation
nonsense that's been pushed by the left
since 2016 the left has completely
flipped on social media
so in 2012 social media was a godsend
why because the obama administration
know how to use it they were micro
targeting people they're using data in
new and innovative ways
then trump used that same information in
very similar ways in 2016
and the meme became the reason that
trump won in 2016 is because facebook
and twitter and youtube didn't shut off
the mechanisms of informational
distribution and misinformation had
decided the election how would we define
misinformation
we defined it as quote not not from the
new york times not from cnn
not from msnbc anything that comes from
a partisan outlet on the right
must be disinformation or misinformation
and this
needs to be stopped the spigot needs to
be closed
so says time magazine laura quinn a
veteran progressive operative who
co-founded catalyst
began studying this problem a few years
ago she piloted a nameless secret
project which she has never before
publicly discussed that tracked
disinformation online
and tried to figure out how to combat it
one component was tracking dangerous
lies that might otherwise spread
unnoticed
researchers then provided information to
campaigners or the media to track down
the sources and expose them okay so
first of all what that sounds like is
that the media are just doing the work
for progressive groups
she's a she's a progressive operative
she runs catalyst catalyst will send
these media updates to members of the
media who will then
ram them into their fact checks the same
way that media matters does
the most important takeaway from quinn's
research says time was that engaging
with toxic content only made it worse
when you get attacked the instinct is to
push back call it out say this isn't
true
but the more engagement something gets
the more popular the more the platforms
boost it
the algorithm reads that as oh this is
popular people want more of it
okay so this is where it gets good so
instead of countering the information
instead of somebody putting out
something that you disagree with and you
counter the information
which by the way you see all the time in
the media and by the way half the time
the media calls something false it
actually isn't false
i saw that last week when snopes decided
to fact check
the idea that that aoc was in the
capital
by admitting that she was not in the
capitol building but saying that it was
mostly false to say that she had
exaggerated her account because she was
not in the capital building it was it
was an amazing fact check
because the way the fact checkers
typically work is that if conservatives
say something false they fact check it
as false which is correct
if the left says something false they
fact check it as mostly true
and if conservatives say something true
they fact check it as mostly false
that's the way these fact checkers often
work and they do it by biasing
exactly what they're fact checking as we
discussed last week okay but
here is the thing what the left was
pushing for was not more engagement
or even more of a boost to content that
rebutted things they thought were not
true instead
the solution she concluded was to
pressure platforms to enforce
their rules both by removing a content
or a con or accounts that spread
misinformation
and by aggressively policing it in the
first place the platforms have certain
policies against certain types of malign
and behavior but they haven't been
enforcing them she says
quinn's research gave ammo to advocates
pushing social media platforms to take a
harder line
in november 2019 mark zuckerberg invited
nine civil rights leaders to dinner at
his home
where they warned him about the danger
of the election-related falsehoods that
were already spreading unchecked
here's the best part of this entire
article you ready it took pushing urging
conversations brainstorming all of that
to get to a place where we ended up with
more rigorous rules and enforcement says
vanita gupta president and ceo of the
leadership conference on civil and human
rights who attended the dinner and also
met with twitter ceo jack dorsey
and others it was a struggle but we got
to the point where they understood the
problem
was it enough probably not was it later
than we wanted yes but it was really
important given the level of official
disinformation that they had those rules
in place and were tagging things and
taking them down
so remember that i said the person who
said that last quote is a person named
vanita gupta
president and ceo of the leadership
conference on civil and human rights
who's saying we got the social media
platforms to mirror our
our recommendations and start taking
down content we didn't like
gupta is joe biden's current nominee to
associate attorney general
does that sound a little corrupt to you
little corrupt to you that people who
are about to enter
the biden administration and we're
essentially part of the adjunct biden
campaign
we're bullying and pressuring social
media companies into taking down
and banning information they didn't like
isn't that kind of a problem
isn't that just a little bit of a
problem and so when you when people say
that they feel like the election was not
honest that can take two forms
one is oh it was voter fraud oh it was
people cheated on the vote
or it could be the reality which is that
there are a lot of people
who are pushing at the top levels from
powerful positions
in order to in order to pull every lever
of influence they could including ones
that have an impact on you
and have an impact on me daily and
that is they call it fortifying the
election
sounds a lot like rigging does it not i
mean
rigging can again for the third time
that's how my voter fraud are voter
regularity when you pull
every weaver of power in order to
achieve a particular result and you do
it top
down does that sound like respect for
the american people or does that sound
like you want to run the place
okay you are being manipulated and the
manipulation continues on a daily basis
this is not about unity it's not about
neutral principles that can be
applied broadly across the spectrum okay
this is about creating monopoly of
informational distribution
a monopoly on who gets punished by the
rules i'm gonna get to that in just
one second first let us talk about an
easy way to make your home look better
so there are a lot of ways to make your
home look better most of them are super
duper expensive
one thing you probably haven't thought
about is your window coverings you walk
into your house you look around you know
it looks pretty nice but
the light's just not coming through you
have kind of dingle curtains look at
them now
i've said it now you're looking at it
now you notice now you need to go to
blinds.com to get that fixed blinds.com
makes it simple to shop top quality
blinds
shades and interior shutters from home
with easy online ordering and free
shipping the experts at blinds.com
understand that window treatments are
one of the household items
you don't think about very much they can
make a huge impact on the look and feel
of your home
you don't need to do a full reno by
simply changing what is on your windows
you can change the way light comes into
your home
and create a totally different feel head
on over to blinds.com just take a look
at all the options they've got
faux wood blinds cellular and roller
shades even outdoor shades and if you're
nervous about trying them no reason to
be because
they've helped millions of homeowners
through the process and they guarantee
the perfect fit whether you do it
yourself or have them measure and
install everything
for you so go right now see how much you
can save at blinds.com
when you check out online don't forget
to tell them you heard about
blinds.com from the ben shapiro show
rules and restrictions
may apply go to blinds.com go check them
out
right now again it's a great way to
upgrade the look and feel of your home
i've used them before they really are
they make it quick they make it easy
it's fantastic go check them out
blinds.com make sure you let them know
at checkout you heard about them on the
ben shapiro show okay so
the manipulation continues a pace
because the members of the media have an
agenda this is why
when you when you see ads like bruce
springsteen ad from jeep
when that pretends that that's an
apolitical ad it's not in a political ad
the suggestion
that we need reuniting after the age of
trump as opposed to you know after
during the age of obama when we actually
did have race riots
when when we did have a an
extraordinarily slow recovery
when we had incredible divisions in the
body politic actually look at the polls
when race relations in america started
to go south was under barack obama
we didn't hear about how he was dividing
america he was a unifier
and then trump came along and he was a
divider and now america is reuniting and
you know what unites us
apparently church is in the middle of
the country that the left doesn't
particularly like
and also dirt those are the things that
unify us but the real answer is what
unifies us is that you listen to the
left
what unifies us what's supposed to unify
us is that you agree
with the precepts of the left and here's
the thing this is directed and my
friends who are liberal but not leftist
i make this distinction
every single day on the program there's
a reason
that we sell leftist tears tumblers not
liberal tears tumblers i explicitly
rejected liberal tears tumblers because
i think liberals are just people who
disagree with me about politics i think
leftists are people who want to see
everybody else banned
in the search for an authoritarian unity
the left is ascendant the left is moving
and they're moving in strong fashion
in order to subject you the citizen
to the curtailment of your right so they
can reach
the sort of unity that they wish again
this is happening inside
supposedly liberal institutions i mean
this is an unbelievable story
okay over at the new york times so the
new york times is just getting purged
right now you remember the story about
james bennett who's their op-ed editor
and you remember that they had an
internal staff rebellion because he had
the temerity to publish a column by tom
cotton remember that it was good times
okay well now they've decided they're
going to purge another person
this person's name is donald mcneil jr
now donald mcneil jr is apparently a
health reporter
and he has a long history of being an
excellent reporter he was nominated for
pulitzer for his for his covet work
now he has resigned and apologized for
his quote-unquote extraordinarily bad
judgment
over his use of the n-word after his
pulitzer prize-winning colleague nicole
hannah jones threatened to launch her
own investigation of him because she is
the de facto editor-in-chief
of the new york times now this
pseudo-journalistic
lying fictionalized anti-american
nicole hannah jones like she she's she's
honestly she's contempt
she's she's a figure who deserves
contempt she deserves intellectual
contempt she's a person
who has rejected any criticism of her
own project
as racist she's gone back and
self-edited her own project
and changed the nature of the project
she she has made accusations that are
completely
unfulfilled about a wide variety of
journalists from from liberal to
conservative
nicole hannah jones is everything that
is wrong with modern day american
journalism
she she's an activist opinion hack
masquerading as something more and she's
not and by the way
a lot of what she says is just plain
wrong it's just anti-factual okay so
here's what happened
in a letter to staff on friday donald
mcneil jr announced he was standing down
from the paper
after 45 years saying he quote
originally thought the context in which
i used this ugly word could be defended
but now realized it cannot so it sounds
like
he had you know called someone the
n-word right i mean usually when you
have a scandal and
you get fired for using the n-word it's
because you called somebody the n-word
right that's not what happened here
that's not what happened here
top bosses had previously said he should
be given another chance saying that
mcniel had not used the word with
malicious or hateful intent
during the times sponsored school trip
but then changed tactics on friday
telling staff quote we do not tolerate
racist language
regardless of intent do you know how
insane that is that standard
we don't tolerate racist language
regardless of intent understand what is
packed into
that small phrase okay normally
when you accuse somebody of being a
racist it's because they have racist
thoughts right it's all about intent
racism is all about intent because there
are actions that can be interpreted a
wide variety of ways
when a cop pulls over a black person for
speeding is that cop doing something
racist or is the cop
pulling somebody over for speeding who
happens to be black we don't know until
we search the officer's intent
until we know something about the
officer but according to the new york
times
racist words do not need to have intent
attached to them
they are on their face racist so we can
disconnect racism from intent okay what
this really is
is the ibramax kenzie idea that what is
truly racist is not intent racism has
nothing to do with intent you can be a
racist without intent
what does it take to be a racist without
intent not mirroring the priorities of
nicole hannah jones
and not taking the perspective of the
woke the woke staffers
that is racist right and and we don't
need to prove intent we don't need to
prove you're a racist
all we have to do is find an instant in
which you said a not
racist thing that's all we have to do
if you use a word in a not racist
context we will still say that you are a
racist even if it is provable that you
are not a racist
so what exactly happened well the
ousting of the man is according to the
daily mail was the paper star coven 19
reporter came
after a group of 150 staffers sent a
letter to the executive leadership
wednesday saying they were deeply
disturbed by the paper's handling of the
incident and demanding a full
investigation into quote-unquote
newly surfaced complaints against mcneal
hannah jones the reporter behind the
1619 project
also vowed to call parents and students
who took part in the trip in question
to find out what mcneil said and in what
context sources told the daily beast
so here's what happened the daily beast
first reported last week multiple
students and parents had lodged
complaints against mcniel back in 2019
after he allegedly used the n-word said
white privilege does not exist
and made disparaging comments about
black people during a company-sponsored
school trip to peru
now there's only one thing there that
really got him fired
the thing that got him fired is that he
said that he doesn't believe in the
concept of white privilege
that's what got him fired it was not the
use of the n-word because you know what
the context was when he was using the
n-word
you know what actually happened what
actually happened is this
here is his letter quote to the staff of
the times on a 2019 new york times trip
to peru for high school students
i was asked at dinner by a student
whether i thought a classmate of hers
should have been suspended for a video
she had made as a 12 year old in which
she used a racial slur
to understand what was in the video i
asked if she had called someone else
this lore or whether she was wrapping or
quoting a book title
and asking the question i use it the
slur itself
that's that that's it that's the whole
thing that's the whole thing
right this is this report that a a
person asked a high school student asked
i know a 12 year old to use the n
and mcneil said oh well did they use the
word bleep
as like a rap lyric or did they use it
not as a as a rap lyric
that should make it right that is
literally what he's literally saying is
what was the intent
what was the intent right was the intent
racist or is the intent not racist that
makes a difference
the times has rejected the standard
however to even say the n word to
clarify
means that you have done something
racist even if you are attempting to
clear like
if i were to get on the air today and
say that n word is a racist term that
should never be uttered by anyone but i
would actually say the n word
the left would demand that i be canceled
that's the way that this works now
if you use the n word to condemn the n
word you will now be cancelled
that's how insane this is these are the
people you're supposed to unify with
how i like hell that's my question
i want bruce springsteen to tell me how
i'm supposed to unify with this so
good-hearted liberals how can you unify
with this
hey mcneil says quote i should not have
done this first of all
number one never apologize to the mob
never apologizing to the bang jackass
mob
never apologize to the woke mob there is
never anything good that has ever come
from apologizing to a woke mob for doing
nothing wrong
he didn't do anything wrong here and the
fact that he apologized
i understand he was doing it to try to
keep his job it's an act of cowardice he
shouldn't have apologized and by the way
the minute that you apologize they will
take your head that is the way that this
works
originally said matilda i thought the
context in which i used this ugly word
could be defended i
now realize it cannot it is deeply
offensive and hurtful
the fact i even thought i could defend
it itself showed extraordinarily bad
judgment for that i apologize
to the students on the trip i extend my
sincerest apology but my apology needs
to be broader than that
not just to the students he needs to
apologize to aliens who have not yet
visited earth
my lapse of judgment has hurt my
colleagues in science the hundreds of
people who trusted me to work with them
closely during this pandemic the team at
the daily that turned to me during this
frightening year and the whole
institution which put its confidence in
me and expect it better
why don't just apologize to the world
kneel before zod kneel before zod so i
have a question
liberals do you feel like kneeling
before the woke dots of hannah nicole
jones is that the world you want to live
in
is that the unity that you are willing
to achieve that you are willing to go
along with people who get people fired
from their jobs
for saying things that are not racist
because you don't like their political
point of view
that's the way that this works now and
by the way the woke will continue along
this mission and they don't need
evidence
evidence don't be silly they don't need
evidence all they want to do is ruin
people that's all this is about it's
about castigating people they disagree
with as evil
this is why taylor lorenz of the new
york times who basically just reports on
like things happening at tick tock
journalism incredible journalism at the
new york times these days
so you know what she tried to do the
other day she tried to go after the
the silicon valley investor mark
andreessen she suggested that he used
the r word right the r word is a
reference
historically to people who had mental
disabilities
i'm not going to say it because as we
know once you say the r word to even
clarify what the r word is you get
canceled that's the way this works
okay so there's only one problem mark
andreessen never said it
that's all that happened mark andreessen
never said it taylor lorenz
tried to smear him according to glenn
greenwald
who has emerged as a voice of sanity i
mean this is how wild things are
glenn greenwald i disagree with about
like all the things is now a voice of
sanity when it comes to this sort of
stuff he says the profound pathologies
driving all of this were on full display
on saturday night
as the result of a reckless and
self-humiliating smear campaign by one
of the new york times star tech
reporters taylor lorenz
she falsely and very publicly accused
silicon valley entrepreneur investor
mark andreessen of having used the slur
word during a discussion about the
reddit gamestop uprising lauren's lied
andreessa never said the word
and rather than apologize and retract it
she justified her mistake by claiming it
was a male voice that sounded like his
then locked her twitter account as
though she
was the victim it's it's like
unbelievable by the way you know how
this happened because there was an app
called clubhouse i've been invited to
use that app i haven't joined it
for specifically this reason and i told
by the way the people who created it
this would happen
clubhouse was supposed to be a place for
people who are prominent to be able to
have open conversations
people like taylor lawrence then logged
in in order to find gotcha moments so
they could go after famous people
because this is what the new left lives
for and they're not doing it because
they care about mark andreessen they're
not doing it because they care about
donald mcneil they're doing it because
they care about you
they're doing it because they hate your
guts because let them be an example
let us put this head on a pike like game
of thrones
to warn off all of those who might
descend it could be your head on that
pike next
okay that is what is going on and by the
way it could be your head on the
social media pike next i'll give you the
greatest example of this
in just a second it truly is it truly is
astonishing by the way
again they will go after anyone and it's
it's places that were formerly liberal
and now are leftists the aclu right the
american
civil liberties union right they're all
about civil liberties right like free
speech and
they'll die for your right to to say it
even if they don't agree with what
you're saying
now they have this ridiculous human
being chase strangio
who is they're one of their lawyers he's
one of their lawyers
the most famous lawyer maybe tweeting
out that jk rowling and abigail schreier
quote and the rest of them
are closely aligned with white
supremacists in power
their rhetoric in turn creates dangerous
policy proposals and eventually laws we
have a lot of mobilizing to do always
good
when you have the aclu their lawyer
calling for the censorship of people
they disagree with and smearing them
as white supremacist fellow travelers
again the warning is to you it's not the
jk rowling it's not to abigail
it's to you the warning is to you and
i'll explain how much of the warning is
to you in a second with this incredible
piece from the la times we'll get to
that
in just one moment first let's talk
about your sleep quality so
you know you got to have a great
mattress we know this you have to have
great sheets we know this too
one thing you may not have thought about
is that pillow you need an
excellent pillow to sleep upon my pillow
their products are not going to go flat
you can wash and dry them as many times
as you want
they maintain their shape best of all
they are made right here in the united
states
if you don't have a my pillow or you
know somebody who doesn't now is the
time to get one for a limited time my
pillow is offering their premium my
pillow
for their lowest price ever you can get
a queen size premium my pillow regularly
69.98 for just 29.98 that's 40 bucks in
savings
kings are only five bucks more folks now
is the time to buy
not only are you getting the lowest
price ever they are the best gifts they
are a fantastic fantastic gift
29.98 for a queen size premium my pillow
by now they'll extend that 60-day
money-back guarantee to march first
20 21. we've got my pillows on our bed
using them every night they're great
they've helped me relieve back pain
because if i sleep the wrong way i get
back pain my pillow helps me with that
the pillow doesn't just turn into a
pancake
go to mypillow.com click on that radio
listener square there you will find not
only this amazing offer but also deep
discounts on all my pillow products
including the giza dream bed sheet
the my pillow mattress topper and my
pillow towel sets or call 800-651-1148
and use promo code daily wire again call
800-651-1148
and use promo code daily wire right now
and go to or go to mypillow.com and
click on that radio listener square to
get started
all right we'll get to more of this in
just a second because this campaign the
misinformation campaign the real
manipulation
it is aimed at you and shutting you up
but first
everybody you probably heard me talk
about our all-access membership before
for those of you
who have not it is our most elite
membership level here at the daily wire
our all access members they get
two leftist tiers tumblers when they
sign up being an all-access member means
they get to watch full coverage of all
daily wear shows
not to mention our feature film and soon
to be coming entertainment
content what's more they get to tune
into exclusive all access live that's a
show that features a different daily
wear host every day where all access
members can chat with us
in the chat box you ask me questions i
answer your questions
it's a lot of fun i sing songs i do
silly dances i tell jokes i do tricks
with my fellow candlesticks
i tell stories about my kids and i
answer your political questions and life
questions as well
it is it is spicy so today we want to
publicly thank all of our all-access
members for their commitment
to the daily wear to show our
appreciation we are mailing out a
special
anniversary tumbler for all renewing all
access members this year let me show you
this tumblr okay this thing is magical
you ready for this
oh look at this this is magnificent look
at this
on the front you have the leftist tears
on the back
all of our signatures and a short
statement about our belief that
america's best days are still ahead
this is a commemorative piece to our
five year journey and a thank you to our
all access members in particular for
supporting
who we are and what we do if you're an
all access member and you're renew
you get this one it's exactly what you
get is a perfect valentine's day if it
comes in a beautiful red
you can give it to somebody who either
needs to catch their own tiers because
they're on the left
uh or to store tears of others it is
look at this it's magnificent it's so
beautiful
and moving and i just know that it'll do
wonders for your love life so go check
it out
right now you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show
in the nation
so the manipulation of the body politic
it's about you it's about mobilizing
people against people like you if you
disagree and i'm again i'm not talking
about if you're conservative
i'm talking about if you dissent from
the local orthodoxy in any way
okay and you think you're safe if you're
on if you're a liberal if you agree with
the left on some of their policy
priorities you think you're safe you're
not you're not safe for one
moment in time the minute you become
inconvenient they run you over
so here's the thing about the left if
you are a normal human being
then generally you're a little
uncomfortable about the idea of the mob
but you like people individually right
you like people on an individual level
you want those people to be treated
decently
but the idea of the mob you know the
idea of the people collectively being
the big deciders
that's a little bit uncomfortable that's
why we like checks and balances in the
united states
if you are on the left they love
quote-unquote the people but they hate
individuals and if you are in their way
they will
run you over as though they are in a
ford f-150 truck and you are just
standing out there
in their way that is that is all that
the left is i mean
the left is just a machine for running
people over in the pursuit of utopia
okay so if you believe as a is a
good-hearted liberal who just disagrees
with me about tax rates and about
abortion
and about key issues right we can have
those key disagreements but if you agree
with me about individual rights
like freedom of speech and the ability
to disseminate information and have
discussions with people across the other
side of the aisle
then you're gonna have to make a
decision do you wish to move along
with the woke left because you agree
with them on policy
and run over rights in the process or do
you wish to preserve rights and maybe
it'll make it a little bit tougher for
you to convince people
of your political agenda but at least
you'll preserve the rights that's the
decision that's going to be up to
people who are liberals but not leftists
okay that's your choice not up to me
it's up to you
okay because they're coming for everyone
okay
i'm gonna give you an example it doesn't
matter how nice you are there's a
perfect example of individuals not
mattering all that matters
well see here's the thing on the left
what they actually believe is that your
belief system
it's so weird they believe that your
belief system is what makes you good or
bad
you can be a perfectly crappy human
being but if you believe the right
things this makes you a good human being
normal people believe that it's the
things you do on a daily basis that make
you a good human being
it's your aspiration to continue to do
more good things on a daily basis that's
what makes you
a good human being folks on the left on
the hard left
they believe that you can be the nicest
person in the world but if you believe
the wrong things they will run you over
so here's a perfect example this this
comes struck me so hard over the weekend
it's a piece by a woman named virginia
heffernan virginia heffernan
writing for the los angeles times it's
called what can you do
about the trumpets next door quote oh
heck no
the trump lights next door to our
pandemic getaway who seem as devoted to
the ex-president as you can get without
being q fans
just plowed our driveway without being
asked and did a great job
how am i going to resist demands for
unity in the face of this act of
aggressive niceness
on some level of course i realize i owe
them things
and man it really looks like the guy
back dragged the driveway like a pro but
how much
thanks these neighbors are staunch
partisans of blue lives
and there aren't a lot of anything other
than white lives in this neighborhood oh
my god they like cops
holy they like cops this is also kind of
weird
back in the city people don't sweep up
other people's walkways for nothing
maybe it's like what eddie murphy
discovered in that old saturday night
live sketch white like me
he goes undercover and white makeup and
finds that when white people are moving
among their own
they pop free champagne and live the
high life as murphy puts it slowly i
began to realize that when white people
are alone
they give things to each other for free
hezbollah the shiite islamist political
party in lebanon
also gives things away for free the
favors hezbollah does for people in the
cities
tyr and si don probably don't involve
snowplows but like other mafias
hezbollah tends to atone
the shiite sick elderly and hungry they
offer protection and hospitality and win
loyalty that way
and they also demand devotion to their
brutal us versus them anti-sunni cause
some of us are family the favor say the
rest are infidels the same is true with
louis farrakhan who currently helms the
nation of islam this person is crazy
this person needs to be in a rubber room
like immediately like put this person in
a straitjacket and drag them to the who
house this is like well the southern
poverty law center classifies him as a
dangerous anti-semite much of his flock
says he's just a little screwy and
unfailingly magnanimous to them
when someone helps you when you're down
or snowden it's almost impossible to
regard them as a blight on the world
in fact you're more likely to be
overwhelmed with gratitude and convinced
of the person's inherent goodness
you might end up like the upper-class
family i stayed with in france as a
teenager
they did not attend a citywide
celebration for the 100th birthday of
charles de gaulle the war hero who
orchestrated the liberation of his
country from nazi germany in 1944.
they did have several portraits of
philippe petain nazi collaborator on
their wall
when i screwed up the courage to ask how
it was for them during the occupation
the lady of the house replied we were
happy because the nazis were very pulis
i didn't know the word so i excused
myself to consult a french english
dictionary i was in tears when i found
the entry
polite so when i accept generosity from
my pandemic neighbors acknowledging the
legitimate kindness with a wave or a
plate of cookies
am i also sealing us in as fellow
travelers
are very polished to each other but not
so much to them now let it be said
there are certain perspectives on the
world that can actually make you a bad
person right if you believe that slavery
is a good idea this can make you a bad
person
if you believe in the murder of all
members of
x group this can make you a bad person
but
she is currently likening a trump
supporter who plowed
her driveway for her to hezbollah
louis farrakhan and the nazis
i have a feeling that this person's
belief are making her an actual honest
to goodness
in daily deed bad person
as this person says loving your neighbor
is evidently much easier when your
neighborhood is full of people just like
you i love that she's just throwing it
like how does she know
if she'd if she were black how does she
know the neighbors wouldn't come over
and plow the driveway
does she know that she has no evidence
of that whatsoever other than her own
unjustified moral superiority and belief
that her next-door neighbors for being
trump supporters must be vicious nazi
racists who would only do this for a
person living in a store who's white
just thrusting that on them
she doesn't know them at all literally
the only thing the only two things she
knows about them
are that they're nice and plow her
driveway for her and did her favor and
they voted for trump so instead of her
saying to herself
it's instead of saying to herself you
know maybe it's possible that some trump
supporters are nice people
and i've miscast and mischaracterized
many trump supporters and their belief
systems
instead of her thinking that it's no it
must be they who are wrong
it must be i whom the morally wonderful
one
okay i don't care what dirt this person
lives on with me
we ain't in the same country if she like
that that's this is wild stuff
she says what do we do about the trump
bites around us like representative
alexander ocasio-cortez who spoke
eloquently this week
about her terrifying experience during
the insurrection at the capitol on
january 6th
americans are expected to forgive and
forget before we've even stitched up our
wounds
or gotten our vaccines against the
pandemic that former president trump
utterly failed to mitigate
my neighbors supported a man who showed
near murderous contempt for the majority
of americans
they kept him in business with their
support but
the plowing on january 6th after the
insurrection
senator ben sasse issued an awesome plea
for all americans to love their
neighbors
at the time i seethed the capital hadn't
just desecrated but maybe my neighbor
heard sass and was determined to make a
bid for reconciliation
so here's my response to the plowed
driveway for now politely but not
profusely i'll acknowledge the sassy and
move
with a wave and a thanks a minimal start
on building back trust
i'm not ready to knock on the door with
a covered dish yet
i also can't give my neighbors
absolution it's not my gift
nobody asks you for absolution you crazy
person nobody
what what are you absolving them of is
it a nice thing for you and have
different
views on politics and your answer is
they're asking you for absolution but
you can't give it honestly
if i were these people's if i was this
lady's neighbor and i read this piece
i would take my snow cloud i would go
out into the street i'd gather as much
snow as humanly possible and dump it
directly on her driveway
i'd pile that sucker like eight feet
high and she can dig that
she can dig that out with a with a
trowel for all i care
what a nasty piece of goods seriously
but this is the work
do you feel the unity do you feel it i
feel the unity and i especially feel the
unity
when elise in our society mirror this
perspective and then mobilize the levers
of power
in order to push forward this
perspective such that if you disagree
with them it's because you just want to
break the country
i love this she says i can offer a
standing invitation to make amends not
with a snowplow but by recognizing the
truth about the trump administration and
more importantly by working for justice
for all those
whom the administration harmed so in
other words i don't care that you did a
nice thing for me
only when you bow before zod only when
you agree with me
will you be deemed one of the morally
elect
this is the woke priesthood at work so
which side you want to be on liberals
this is my question on the other side of
virginia heffernan should sound like
somebody that you want to live next door
to
or would you like to live in the same
neighborhood as the trump supporter who
disagrees with you
on tax rates and immigration but also
might plow your driveway once in a while
and recognizes that you actually
are brothers in arms against many of the
myriad ills that
that wreck countries all over the world
historically
there can be no unity with this there
can't and if people who agree with this
sort of stuff control the levers of
power
there will not be any unity it's just
going to get worse
it's just going to be worse from here on
in alrighty so
michael knowles is guest hosting hour
too and you can listen to his show
today it should be up very very shortly
in the meantime
i will see you here tomorrow i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producers are
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez
the show is edited by adam's psy events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica crams
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021.
house democrats strip a republican
representative of her committee
assignments
time magazine admits to an election
conspiracy and liz cheney
wants to be the future of the republican
party check it out on the michael
knowles show
[Music]